right-hander michael walker on the mound
11th pitch of the at-bat he lines it
right to frazier he drops it but he'll
make the throw to first base and that
retires the side
john means last year an all-star for the
two two orioles
to short could be two there's one on to
first and it's a tailor-made double play
here's dj stewart who had himself a
weekend
there's there's the dragons see
have another one way back and it's gone
upper deck dj stewart
wow you talk about hot 98 miles an hour
off the bet 386 feet give the orioles a
two nothing lead two balls and no
strikes against rio ruiz is riding an
eight-game hitting streak right now 2-0
pitch hit sharply on the ground and
through the left side cedric mullins
last one coming up against waka
and there's a line drive into the right
field corner mullins with extra bases
ruiz into third and they'll hold them up
there
cedric mullins with a two out double top
frazier to lead it off for the mets in
the second
focal pitch that's a strike and todd
frazier will sit down here's mariznick
with two out nobody on
and he gets one of the air to left field
back goes mount castle to the warning
track at the wall leaping and it's out
of here
jake marisnick clears the wall and left
for his second home run of the year to
cut the orioles lead in half
looks like he got that ball down off the
end of the bat but it carried
jose iglesias digging in against michael
walker there's a base hit and palacious
lines one into left and the orioles have
the lead off hitter on it here in the
third ryan outcast in the battle mount
castle struck out on a change up back in
the second inning
here's the pitch
and this one's hit the center field and
deep back goes maurizio still going back
back to the track he's running out of
room and that one is gone it's a two-run
home run for ryan mount castle
four to one baltimore number four
for the orioles left fielder cedric
mullins digs in he doubled to right
field his first time up an rbi
opportunity
and there's a line drive in the gap
that's going to be extra basis could be
a three bagger valika scores mullins
racing around second headed to third
and he slides head first with a triple
three bag rbi for cedric mullins who
keeps producing 5-1 orioles yeah this is
i think the best we have seen john means
look oh there's the hook again
they'll have to throw down to first
alonso out on strikes means is retired
seven straight now up steps pedro
severino
lined into left center
base hit
where is nick cuts it off severino
digging for two
and he's in sliding with a double some
runners on the corner with two down and
pat felika steps in
now swinging a ground ball headed up the
middle diving pick up by the shortstop
for sorry it doesn't spin throws to
first up
valenca lengths it out severino down to
score
and the orioles lane is six to one
now two on two down for rio ruiz
that's it well down the right field line
and it is gone a three run shot for rio
ruiz
and the orioles jump up
9-1
second hit of the night for ruiz this
one a loud one third homer of the game
the orioles have scored seven runs on
home runs
john means has been excellent on the
mound there it is for the strikeout
well done
got him with a high fastball
three straight strikeouts for john means
four in the game
and nine straight he's set down in order
third straight battery's gone full
there's his swing gonna miss strike
three
means with strikeout number five
challenge davis with a fastball
2-2 pitch rolled on the ground to first
backhanded by valencia calls off means
steps on the bag they got him john means
six innings of one run baseball the run
scored for valleca very respectable 276
batting average
that's it well
isn't it going back won't catch up with
this one there goes way back
home run pat valenka pat the bat number
six wow
talk about turning one around
you mentioned it there's some popping
that bat in limited action last year
with the rockies they only hit one home
run in 78 at bats
and there's a base hit
off the glove of rosario into left field
and it's an rbi for iglesias
as alberto trots home with run number
11.
here's mcneil who has a hit and a walk
tonight one for two
and mcneal crushes one to right field
and he is homeward for the third
straight game
so mcneal has broken out the power
stroke over the last three days
no home runs before sunday and now he's
homered three games in a row
and that makes it 11-2
jake mariznick
has had a good night for the mets one of
the few this should do it oh hang on
velasquez with a bobble but gets the out
at second base
and the mets are retired and the orioles
have an 11-2 win